Now that we have acquired our data, whether the
informal flat file SQL like relational database, or an API,
you might think we are ready to dive in
and do some analysis. Alas, I am afraid, we are
not quite there yet. There can often be problems
with our data. It might not be in a format
that allows us to easily perform the desired analysis,
or maybe there's a bunch of bad or missing values.
In this next section, let's discuss how to deal
with these issues so that we can get to the
exciting part of any project, the analysis. Let's talk briefly
about sanity checking our data. What does it mean to
sanity check data? Well, put briefly, if we're sanity checking
data we want to quickly determine, does the data make
sense? Is there a problem? Does the data look like
I expect it to? There's a ton of work you
can do to sanity check your data. We can
draw plots to visualize the data. You can run some
basic analyses and tons of other things. I don't want
to focus too much on this in this course. If
you'd like to dive deep into the subject, I'd recommend
taking you down to these exploratory data and analysis course.
However, to do just the bare amount of sanity checking,
Pandas DataFrames do have a useful method called the Scribe.